y les digo a todos nuevamente feliz año
nuevo lunar es que varios países
asiáticos festejan el inicio del año el
tigre de agua las festividades suelen
extenderse hasta por 15 días aunque la
propagación de el coronavirus afecta a
las celebraciones por como ya ha sabido
las personas nacidas en el año del tigre
se enfrentarán a un vengan ya su propio
año zodiac al en este 2022 según los
creyentes esto significa que habrá más
perturbaciones y también inestabilidad
en el año venidero pues no están muy
bien las cosas entonces para estas
personas que cumplen y que nacieron en
este año del tigre pero para conocer más
sobre este año nuevo lunar vamos a
hablar entonces consiguiente ay es
integrante del programa de
interculturalidad de casa asia gracias a
siguen por estar con nosotros en directo
américa de france 24 le pregunto lo
básico que este año nuevo lunar y por
qué llevan nombres de animales
antes de todo siguen sin dar infusión
way es una petición en chino
bueno el año del tigre significa en por
ejemplo tenemos un ciclo de 12 animales
y es un ciclo y este año es para el
tigre y el tigre suele significar que la
gente es más valiente que le gusta los
desafíos que es muy fuerte y tal en y si
como dice usted este año es para los de
ti que son para niña y en china tenemos
llevar algo rojo para combatir este este
esta suerte
como como no se le abran ustedes en
china cosa como es un día típico del
recibimiento de este año nuevo lunar
como como lo celebran en su casa a lo
mejor que comen cuál es la tradición más
bonita que tienen ustedes para recibir
este año nuevo
hoy tenemos muchas cosas para hacer en
china por ejemplo
ayer el de ayer es que se llama tania y
que es el como la noche de paz aquí y
hoy cocinamos un montón de comida y
reunimos con la familia con los amores y
recibimos como hija recibimos dinero
como en un gran embudo y si con dinero
significa suerte en una caja roja
reciben este dinero entonces para
recibir la prosperidad me imagino en
este en este año no sé también pues
hablemos obviamente esta celebridad de
estas celebraciones perdón que se han
vivido en momentos de pandemia de ccoo y
19 esto igual pues digamos ahí las
festividades en las ciudades que se han
disminuido las han cancelado pero igual
sigue el espíritu vivo no sé si a lo
mejor tiene en familiares y amigos en
china que le dicen de cómo ha cambiado
esto con la pandemia de kobe 19
creo que en defectos no hay mucho efecto
por el porqué
es este festival es para familiares y
luego en celebramos dentro de la familia
pero a lo mejor si afecta en el sentido
de visitar familiares por ejemplo el
steve el festivo no es solo estos días
en los días siguientes visitamos
familiares y cenamos juntos pero con
este kobe este tema de kobe a lo mejor
no es tan seguro y a lo mejor a las
personas se preocupa un poco y en en
china tenemos red de restricciones muy
sectas estrictas pues a lo mejor algunas
personas no pueden volver a casa y tal
este penal siguiente sí según éste este
calendario lunar ya animales son los
mejores digamos para para nacer cuáles
son los que tienen mejor augurio cuáles
son los más fuertes los que no tienen
ningún riesgo digamos que sea un año
malo
uy esta pregunta es un poco esta vez sí
tenemos nos gusta algunos animales por
ejemplo el el tigre es muy bueno la
gente le gusta a la gente le gusta pero
a lo mejor el snake el snake lo
sorprendió
en la cabra no tanto
a la gente a la gente le gusta mucho del
dragón cuál es cuál está en china
cuál es su hogar es el millones animal
perdonen
yo soy de vaca la vaca y que representa
la vaca
por ejemplo muy trabajadora que con el
que tolera mucho y es un buen animal
también
bueno siguiente bien le quiero preguntar
ya hablamos de cómo se celebra este año
nuevo lunar dentro de china digamos y
los países asiáticos y también hablamos
de esta pues problemática del coi 19 que
ha mermado estas celebraciones a gran
escala en las calles pero ya dijiste que
obviamente era algo también más familiar
más interno pero digamos para las
personas que no viven dentro de china
dentro de los países de origen como lo
celebran a nivel internacional
por ejemplo yo estoy en en españa
barcelona yo reúno unos amigos y
cocinamos juntos con mis compis ya tengo
7 y muy muy chulos
y este también digamos una festividad
para ustedes no se tener como unas
nuevas metas unos propósitos digamos
para una persona
occidental una persona que no es
asiática como puede hacer para celebrar
o para meterse en esto este nuevo año
lunar porque muchas personas también no
necesariamente son asiáticas pero si
creen en todo esto en todas estas
costumbres en este nuevo año lunar cómo
hacer entonces para poder iniciar este
proceso de poder creer y poder ser y
poder creer es el animal que nació
digamos
como la gente de aquí si quieres sentir
más estas actividades
por ejemplo la comunidad de china
organizamos algunas actividades por
ejemplo hace unos días días hay una hubo
una ceremonia con actual o actuaciones
chinas muy chulas y la gente de aquí
participan mucho y disfrutan mucho y yo
fui la presentadora de aquella actividad
hay mucha comunidad china en barcelona y
en españa cierto como como es la
convivencia de ustedes y cómo es el
ambiente en estas en la víspera y
también en este año nuevo lunar
no sé siento me siento muy reunidos con
ellos por ejemplo cuando nos encontramos
con algún chino y suelen ser muy amables
con nosotros y tenemos descuento para
comprar algo y tal y creo que sí porque
tenemos como grupos en las redes
sociales y si necesitas algo y puedes
teclear y decir a ellos ya lo mejor te
obtendrás ayuda siguiente bueno ya se
acaba nuestra conversación pero antes de
despedirme quisiera que por favor no
repita ese saludo al principio y también
que no los traduzca al español para
saber qué es lo que significan
lo que ayuda yacimiento a los junio sin
daño y jugo zhongwei significa feliz año
nuevo chino en que que tengas mucha
suerte en este año de tigre y es muy
valiente como el tigre